The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: All right, so let's
do our first clicker question.
All right, let's just
do 10 more seconds.
Interesting.
So, in this problem you were
given the maximum rate, Vmax,
which, by the way, you
calculated in class last time.
And then said what will the
substrate concentration be
when you have half
of that rate.
And so, when you have half of
the maximum rate, that's the
definition of k m.
So all you have to do is if a
k m is given, you just write
down that value.
So that's the level
of question you'll
get on enzyme kinetics.
All right, so that should be
a good tie breaker, too.
All right, so in this little
review and we talk about the
material from the second half of
the course, and why I think
this material is really
important and cool, and that's
because it all represents the
basic principles of how
enzymes work.
And as a biochemist, I recognize
this material is
really important.
So that's what interests me
particularly about it.
And the point that I want to
make in general is that when
you're studying introductory
material, sometimes it seems
like you're never going to
really need that material
again, but that's because you
haven't seen the connection
between it in other topics.
So, a lot of the things you've
learned will be related to
things that you're going
to see you later on.
So I'm going to give you
examples and review examples
of how the material you've
learned will allow you to
understand an enzyme,
for example.
So, we talked last time that one
reason why you care about
understanding how an enzyme
works is because a lot of
people want to inhibit
enzymes.
Well, why would you want to
inhibit enzymes, and that's
because inhibiting enzymes
is very useful to
treat a bunch of things.
A number of you will, in the
next week, I'm pretty sure, be
interested in ways to inhibit
enzymes to prevent headaches
or to decrease headaches.
And this is true of students
and faculty
during finals week.
And so, some of the treatments
for headaches that a number of
those pharmaceuticals are geared
toward enzymes called
prostaglandin synthesis, and
they inhibit those enzyme from
working and that gets rid
of your headache.
Arthritis, for example, is also
treated by a lot of the
same medications that
treat headaches.
Cancer, often chemotherapy
or you're giving people
inhibitors of enzymes to
decrease tumor growth.
And we talked last time about
inhibiting HIV proteases as
part of a treatment for HIV. So,
understanding enzymes is
very important for the
pharmaceutical industry, and
so that's one example of why
you need to know about
chemical equilibrium, why you
need to know about acid based
oxidation reduction transition
metals, and also kinetics.
So, I'm going to give
you a case study.
You've seen some of these
examples before, but we're
going to put them all
together now.
And I try in every lecture, if I
can, to mention vitamin B12,
and here, we're going to tell
you about a vitamin B12
dependent enzyme, and how
knowing what you know now
about these topics would allow
you to understand how this
enzyme works.
So, first, kinetics, this is
easy, methionine synthase,
it's an enzyme.
So, what does this enzyme do?
So this particular enzyme
converts an amino acid called
homocysteine to another amino
acid, methionine.
It also converts another
vitamin, a B vitamin, the
methyltetrahydrofolate form to
tetrahydrofolate, so this
folate is one your B vitamins.
Why do you care?
Well, methionine is needed for
proper formation of brain and
spinal column, and it's
particularly important when
women are pregnant that they
have enough folic acid so that
they can make enough
methionine.
If they do not have enough folic
acid, then you can have
babies born with neural
tube defects.
Also, as I mentioned before,
inhibiting methionine synthase
raises homocysteine levels, so
you can't do this conversion,
and that increases risk
of heart disease that
homocysteine is actually a
really good indicator, high
homocysteine levels of whether
someone's going to have heart
trouble or not.
This is also a target for
chemotherapy, because you need
tetrahydrofolate to do DNA
biosynthesis, and tumor cells
that are growing, tumors that
are growing, need a lot of DNA
biosynthesis.
So if you inhibit this enzyme,
you can inhibit DNA
biosynthesis, so it's
a potential
chemotherapeutic target.
There is some use of
this in Europe.
Actually there is a treatment
that's given that's
specifically supposed to inhibit
methione synthase,
it's not used so much in this
country, but laughing gas will
inhibit methione synthase.
And so, in Europe some cancer
patients are treated with
laughing gas as a way to
decrease their tumors.
I'm not sure it's the most
effective therapy, but they're
at least pretty happy with it.
So that's the counterpart.
So, this is an important
enzyme.
And enzymes, of course, as we
know are catalysts and they
catalyze reactions, so tell me
what you know about catalysts.
Which is the following
statements about
catalysts are true?
OK, let's take 10 more seconds.
Very good.
All right, so going
back to the notes,
statement 2 is true.
So, catalysts work by lowering
the activation energy barrier
for both the forward and
the reverse reaction.
So both rates would
be changed.
And also, catalysts are not
going to affect the
thermodynamics, they're not
going to shift the equilibrium
toward products.
What's something that you
could use to shift an
equilibrium, say, to products
or reactants.
Temperature, yeah.
So, just a little review
of kinetics.
Again, a catalyst works by
lowering the activation energy
barrier, or another way to say
that is by stabilizing a
transition state, so it's going
to affect the activation
energy for the forward
reaction.
And for the reverse reaction,
it's going to decrease both of
them by the same amount.
So if you know how much one is
decreased, you also know how
much the other is decreased.
And we also know that it
doesn't affect the
thermodynamics.
So, does it change the
equilibrium constant?
No, it doesn't change the
equilibrium constant.
All right, so a little
review of kinetics.
So now let's talk about
transition metals.
So this particular enzyme needs
2 different kinds of
transition metals.
It needs cobalt in the form of
vitamin B12 and it also needs
zinc. So we talked about
methylcobalamin, so cobalamin
is another name for
vitamin B12.
And here we have a methyl
ligand, c h 3 is a methyl
ligand coordinated to the cobalt
in the center, and we
saw before that when you have a
thing that forms attachments
at more than one point, it's
called a chelate, so the corn
ring here is a chelating agent,
and it's a tetradentate
ligand because there are
4 points of attachment.
So we can have monodentate,
bidentate, tetradentate,
hexadentate, and tell you
the number of points of
attachment.
And again, this is a chelate,
and what do you know about a
chelate effect?
I want someone to tell me what
the chelate effect is, and
there's a special bonus
prize of a teeshirt
for the best answer.
Who wants to give it a try
and tell me what the
chelate effect is.
Any volunteers?
Bonus teeshirt.
Who wants to give it a try.
Not very brave.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: OK, so chelate, it's
something that's going to
be binding to a metal at
multiple points of attachment.
And what do we know about how
stable or how favorable that
kind of interaction is?
STUDENT: It makes it more stable
because [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Are you reading
from your notes?
Well, you know what, I didn't
say that was not allowed, so
congratulations.
Right, so chelates are unusually
stable due to
entropic affects.
So it's an entropy affect.
So if you have a metal that's
free in solution, it's going
to bind to a lot of water
molecules, and often, metals
like to bind to thick things.
You see a lot of octahedral
complexes.
So if you have a metal bound to
6 waters, and you bring in
a chelate that will blind with
multiple points of attachment,
such as EDTA, which binds at 6
points of attachment, that 1
molecule of EDTA will displace
6 water molecules.
So that is going to be
entropically favorable.
6 things floating around in
solution have a lot more
entropy than 1 thing floating
around in solution.
And this makes chelates
very stable.
And so, if you want to get --
if someone is poisoned with
the metal and you want to get
that metal out of your system,
you give them a chelate such as
EDTA, hospitals have EDTA.
It's also good, as we learned,
for cleaning bath tubs.
All right, so that's
the chelate effect.
All right, so what about zinc.
This enzyme has a zinc and it
has zinc in the plus
-- zinc plus 2 ion.
So, if you know that, you
can calculate a d count.
And so again, we can go
to our periodic table.
What group is zinc in?
12.
So what would be the d count?
10.
So 12 minus 2 equals 10.
So what would you think would
be true about the color of
this d 10 system?
All right, so let's just
take 10 more seconds.
All right, so it would
be colorless.
And so, all of the d orbitals
are going to be full, and so
there's no transition from one
set of d orbitals to the
other, and so it would be
a colorless compound.
And that is, in fact, true that
it took years and years
of studying methionine synthase
before people
realized that it had a zinc in
it, no one knew that there was
a zinc, because they
couldn't see it.
It didn't add a color, and so
no one knew that a metal was
there for a long time.
All right, so what about
oxidation reduction?
So, this enzyme does
a lot of different
oxidation reduction reactions.
So, when it reacts with
homocysteine to form
methionine, and the vitamin
B12, which is shown in a
cartoon form down here, goes
from a plus 3 state that has
the methyl associated, it gives
the methyl group, the c
h 3 group, up to homocysteine
to form methionine, and then
you're in a plus 1 state
of cobalt here.
But this state can lose an
electron, and you can have a
what's called Co(II) form of the
enzyme, which you need to
put another electron in and
reduce it to go back, and you
also need to methylate
it again.
And the methyl group comes from
s adenosylmethionine.
So, we need to think about how
we're going to reduce the
vitamin to get it back in its
primary turnover state.
so, we know the redox
potentials for this.
The standard reduction
potential for vitamin
B12 is minus 0 .
5 2 6 volts.
The potential reduction
potential for flavodoxin,
which is the protein that gives
it the 1 electron, and
it's a flavin protein, which
is another B vitamin.
And that's minus 0 .
2 3 0 volts.
So, what do we know
about these?
Tell me which is the better
reducing agent.
All right, let's just
do 10 more seconds.
Click in your responses.
OK.
So, vitamin B12 is a better
reducing agent.
If you have a large negative
number, then the reduced
species is very reducing.
So it wants to reduce
other things and
get oxidized itself.
So, that's interesting.
It seems like vitamin B12 should
be reducing flavodoxin
and not the other way around.
So we can look at how
unfavorable this process is,
and we can calculate a standard
potential for this,
and we can use this equation
where we have reduction minus
oxidation and plug the values
in, and so we have a minus 0 .
5 2 6 minus a minus of the
floating potential, and that
gives us a negative
value for delta e.
So is this reaction
spontaneous?
No, and that's because if you
have a negative standard
reduction potential, then
you're going to have a
positive value for delta g, so
it will not be spontaneous.
And again, you can calculate the
value for delta g, so we
have minus n, number of moles
of electrons, Faraday's
constant times the difference
in potential, and it's a one
electron process, we put in
Faraday's constant and the
calculated value for delta e,
and we get a positive 28 .
6.
And as I mentioned before in
class, the way this reaction
goes is that at the same time an
electron goes in, you also
cleave s adenosylmethionine,
which gives the methyl group
to also return to the catalytic
cycle, and that
process is very favorable
minus 37 .
6 kilojoules per mole.
So it drives the unfavorable
reaction.
So in the body you will have a
favorable oxidation reductions
and you'll have unfavorable
ones.
All right, so what do you a cell
that requires energy to
catalyze a non-spontaneous
reaction?
So, that's an electrolitic
cell.
And a cell that catalyzes
a spontaneous reaction?
Galvanic, right.
So again, with oxidation
reduction, it doesn't matter
if you're talking about a
battery, or if you're talking
about a cellular process, all
the same equations apply.
All right, what about acid
based equilibrium.
So in this particular -- in this
catalytic cycle, we are
converting homocysteine to
methionine, and that chemistry
involves acid base.
So what is true about the
reaction is that the
protonation state of
the substrate,
homocysteine, matters.
So, you can have a protonated
homocysteine, and here's the
structure of homocysteine, a
deprotonated homocysteine
where the sulfur does not
have a proton anymore.
So we have an s minus here.
And this protonated form of
homocysteine can be converted
to methionine where there's a
methyl group attached to the
sulfur here.
So, we want to know at
physiological p h 7 .
4, how much of the homocysteine
is deprotonated?
And here, if you're asking how
much of something is in a
protonated state, how much of
something is in a deprotonated
state, what you are asking
is what is the p k a of
homocysteine.
So what is the p k a
of homocysteine?
That's what you need to know to
figure out how much would
be in the protonated state,
how much would be in the
deprotonated state.
So here, the p k a is 10.
So now, without doing any
calculations, I want you to
tell me what you expect about
how much is protonated and how
much is deprotonated at
physiological p h if
the p k a is 10.
All right, let's just take
10 more seconds.
I hope that I mentioned
that acid base will be
on the final exam.
So good thing we're reviewing
it right now.
All right, so now let's
look at the math.
So if you're given a p k a and p
h and asked about a ratio of
protonated to deprotonated
it's OK to pull out your
favorite Henderson Hasselbalch
equation, which gives you a
sense of the ratio, can predict
the ratio, again it's
approximation, but predict the
ratio of protonated to
deprotonated.
H a, of course, being an
abbreviation for protonated, a
minus for deprotonated.
And so we can calculate here
that if you have a p h of 7 .
4, p k a of 10, you get
a ratio of 400:1.
So that's the math, but you can
also just think about it
in terms of what you know.
So let's just do
a brief review.
So the answer here is that
free homocysteine is
protonated and non-reactive
at physiological p h.
But let's just think about this
question a little more.
So this is not a figure in
today's handout, but you've
seen this a few times,
so let's just
look at it for a minute.
So, we talked a lot about
acid based titrations.
We talked about so here we have
a weak acid tritrated
with a strong base.
In the beginning it's a weak
acid problem, at the
equivalence point it's a weak
base problem, because we've
added enough moles of our strong
acid to convert all of
our weak acid to its
conjugate base.
And in the middle when you've
added half the number of the
moles, you've converted half
of your weak acid to its
conjugate, then the p
h is equal to the
p k a at this point.
So that would be right
in the middle of
this buffering region.
Again, in a buffering region
you have quite a bit -- you
have quite a bit of your weak
acid and quite a bit of a
conjugate, so it can buffer.
If strong acid is added, then
it can be used up, if strong
base is added, it can be used
up without changing
the p h very much.
That's a buffer, so the p h
curve is flat in here in that
buffering region.
And so, when you think about
this, if you're at p h's that
are below the p k a, then
you're going to be more
protonated, and p h is above
the p k a, you'll be more
deprotonated.
So let's look at the figure now
that's in today's handout
and think about this.
So when the p h equals the p k
a, you will have equal number
of moles, of something that's
protonated as deprotonated.
And if you're at p h's above
the p k a, you'll be more
deprotonated.
P h's below the p k a, you'll
be more protonated.
And in the particular example
I gave, we have a p k a
of 10, so at 7 .
4 we're at a p h that is below
the p k a, and so here they'd
be more protonated.
So if you do the math
it's 400:1.
But even if you aren't doing
any math, you should think
about the fact that that would
have more of the protonated
form than the deprotonated
form.
All right, but the enzyme has
a problem, because only the
deprotonated form is active.
The p k a of the free
homocysteine is 10, and you're
at physiological p h, so this
reaction doesn't seem
like it should go.
But again, it's an enzyme, and
enzymes catalyze reactions.
So they do things to make
that reaction go faster.
And what this particular enzyme
does is it lowers the p
k a of homocysteine.
So when homocysteine is bound
to the enzyme, it's p k a is
no longer 10, but now
its p k a is 6.
So, how does the
enzyme do this?
Well, that's where the
zinc comes in.
So, the zinc binds to the
homocysteine and it acts as a
Lewis acid as it binds
to the homocysteine.
So the homocysteine is your
donor ligand, and you have
your metal as the Lewis
acid, your acceptor.
And that alters the p k a, so
it actually associates, zinc
associates with this sulfur,
and that changes the p k a.
So, I just wanted to mention
again, I was having dinner
with some of my faculty
colleagues who teach organic
chemistry here.
We were interviewing another job
candidate, and they looked
at me and said, they're teaching
organic this semester
and they said we asked our class
about p k a's, and they
all insisted that they had never
heard about p k a's in
their freshman chemistry
course.
And I, of course, said, well,
they did not take 511-1 then.
So just remember, especially
when it's Barbara Imperiali
asking, did you hear about
p k a's, the answer is?
STUDENT: Yes.
PROFESSOR: Thank you.
OK, so just this week.
So it alters the p k a here.
So now what's our situation?
Well, now at physiological p h,
we have a p k a of 6, and
so that gives us a very
different ratio.
Instead of 400:1,
we have 1:25.
So most of the homocysteine is
deprotonated at physiological
p h, which means that
it can react.
So, if we go back to this now,
our p k a is now 6, and so
physiological p h is now
above that p k a.
So when you're above the p
k a, you should have more
deprotonated than protonated.
So that's how you can
rationalize these things.
All right, now I have to ask,
all right, we do not need a
tie breaker.
So at the end of the lecture,
we will announce the winner.
But let's first do chemical
equilibrium.
Chemical equilibrium.
So we didn't talk too much
about this in chemical
equilibrium, but enzymes can
have alternate conformation,
so the enzyme can change its
shape during chemistry.
And that those conformation
of the enzyme can be in
equilibrium.
So the enzyme itself can be an
equilibrium with different
conformational states.
So here, there are a lot of
states of the enzyme.
It needs to react with
homocysteine, it needs to
react with
methyltetrahydrofolate and
with s adenosylmethionine.
And when the structure was
determined to this enzyme,
here in green is the vitamin
B12, and red
is the methyl group.
You see that the methyl group
is pretty buried, you can
barely see it, but yet it
needs to interact with
homocysteine to give it a methyl
group, it needs to take
a methyl group off
methyltetrahydrofolate, it
also needs to take a
methyl group off s
adenosylmethionine.
But it doesn't seem like there's
any room for any of
them to actually get in there.
So, this was a sign that there
has to be some kind of change
in the structure.
So here's another picture
of the structure.
Here's the vitamin B12 in green,
the methyl group in
red, and there's this whole
protein part up here that has
to get out of the way
to do the chemistry.
And, in fact, we do know from
experimental data that it does
move so you can do
the chemistry.
So that means that the enzyme
has to have a number of
different structures.
It's modular.
Here's the vitamin B12 binding
domain, the vitamin B12,
there's this region that have to
move called the methyl cap.
It needs to interact, the B12
here needs to interact with a
folate domain, a homocysteine
domain, and
an activation domain.
So you need to have at least
these four different
structures, and these four
structures will be in
equilibrium with each other.
So you need to have a structure
with folate, a
binding domain on top of the
red B12, you need to have
homocysteine in yellow on top of
the B12, you need to have a
resting state where those
helices are on top of the B12,
and you need to have an
activation state where the
ado-meth domain is on top of
the B12, and all of these
states are going to be in
equilibrium with each other,
and they're going to be moving,
which means that
enzymes are dynamic,
chemistry is dynamic.
Chemistry in the body is
not in the solid state.
Chemistry in the body
is in solution.